got the u.s 30-year treasury yields to
start with and it's going just up just
looks like it's just taking a little
rocket ship ride here what's going on
with the 30-year
yeah more bonds talk today uh i like i
said last week and i you know i've said
it a bunch on twitter if you want to
understand why bitcoins trading like it
is
look at equities and if you want to
understand why equities are trading like
they are you have to look at credit you
have to look at the bond market uh where
everyone's talking about the inflation
prints and really the biggest impact is
in the bond market so we see the 30-year
treasury but really the entire treasury
curve bending upwards just today just
before it came on actually 30-year
treasury broke above 300 basis points
three percent um and so i think there's
you know there's a trend a secular trend
which i show in the next chart of the 10
year
and kind of this lower high pattern that
we've seen basically for the last four
decades
and so it's getting very very very close
to a lot of these kind of to really a
break in trend of this lower high
pattern and there's a whole lot of debt
out there that you know needs to be
rolled over this is how our monetary
system works
um and so when yields spike like this
not only is the the value of these bonds
getting marked to market lower but at
the same time the financing costs for
all of this debt the hundreds of
trillions of dollars of debt in the
global economy is rising rapidly um so
there's a lot a lot of interesting stuff
happening
what is the issue with uh the breaking
of the trend if that occurs what what
are the ramifications or impact in your
opinion
yeah so i mean essentially just you know
to kind of say it again i think the the
point needs to be hammered home that all
of this debt in the system all this
money supply money is is is dead in this
system money is created through through
lending and it's destroyed through debt
default or repayment and so when debt
has to be rolled over like all debt has
to be rolled over that the us
government's 30 trillion dollars in debt
uh and they're consistently running
higher and higher deficits
they fund themselves through tax
receipts but increasingly it's through
debt and there they were relying in 2020
in 2021 on the federal reserve to
monetize that debt the fed's saying
inflation's running hot we got to step
out of the market and now it's entirely
up to the market
and up to investors to to basically uh
to fund the us government and it's
through that treasury issuance and so
with these yields rising it's getting a
lot more expensive for the treasury and
oh really everyone else from the
corporate world the individual investors
to say mortgage rates uh to finance this
debt and so we're not starting to see
the kind of second-order implications of
this which is really just kind of a
balance sheet crunch but i think that's
to come and i think that's the biggest
story of 2022 so far
yeah it's fascinating to watch this
happen uh you've got this chart here
with uh gold over global bonds uh and
again rising very rapidly what is this
telling you
yeah so why why am i talking about gold
why am i talking about bonds to bitcoin
analysts you know i think really what we
see here this is a multi-decade chart
it's a trend of hard money outperforming
soft money right we have fiat
denominated bond markets selling off in
in a rapid fashion and i have a the bond
the total vanguard total bond market
index in the chart after this that we
can show but essentially gold hard money
spent hard money for millennia against
fiat denominated bonds what's what's
this chart show when when we see the
trend really breaking a huge decade-long
cup and handle pattern well it's showing
that hard money is outperforming soft
money um and so i also like to look at
say like bitcoin versus gold which is
the hardest money against hard money uh
which is consolidating but i think this
this trend this broad trend of hard
money out performing soft money and we
have i have later in the chart we can uh
go over this but it's usd versus jpy the
the japanese yen
the dollar is almost like the cleanest
of the dirty shirts and so while we see
bonds selling off what we see the dollar
really depreciating against real goods
and services uh we see stuff like gold
and i think eventually in my opinion
bitcoin which is consolidating right now
uh going to outperform in a big big way
over the coming coming decades hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time